so
what do you make of anonymity
because it seems to be a fundamental
aspect
of the power of the app right but
at the same time anonymity on the
internet
uh so it protects us right it gives us
freedom to have a voice
but it can also bring out the dark sides
of human nature
like trolls or people who want to be
malicious
want to hurt others purely for the joy
of hurting others
being cruel for fun and
going to the dark places so like what do
you make of anonymity as a fundamental
feature of social interaction
like the pros and the cons yeah just to
break that down a bit
i would say a lot of those same things
about a place like twitter where people
are very
unanimous um having said that of course
there's a different sort of capacity
people have when they're anonymous right
well in all different sorts of ways so
what do i make of anonymity i think it
can be incredibly liberating and a lot
of people be incredibly vulnerable and
to connect in different ways
both on politics and there was a lot to
talk about this year regarding politics
and you know personally vulnerable being
vulnerable talking about relationships
and mental health
i think it allows people to have a
community that's not performative
and of course there's this other side
where you know people
can sometimes break rules or say things
that they
wouldn't otherwise say that people don't
always agree with or that people might
find repugnant
and to an extent these can facilitate
great conversations
and on the other hand we have to have
moderation in place and we have to have
community guidelines
to make sure that the anonymity doesn't
overwhelm the purpose
which is right that anonymity first of
all anime
is a tool in librex it was not the
purpose of librex it is
a way that we get towards these
authentic conversations given our campus
climate
and second of all i would say it's a
spectrum
it's not just it's not just librex is
anonymous
right um because librex
isn't totally anonymous everyone's a
verified ivy league student
you know exactly what school everyone
goes to you only have
one account per person at yale meaning
if um
meaning that i mean what that amounts to
is people have more of an ownership in
the community
and people know that they're connected
and they have a common vernacular
so the anonymity is a scale and it's a
tool but you can also trust
i mean this is the difference between
reddit anonymity
where you can easily create multiple
accounts
when you have only one account per
person
or at least it's very difficult to
create multiple accounts
then you can trust that the anonymous
person you're talking to
is a human being not a bot
you